just before we get started members can I
just check that you've all received a
copy of the addendum and that you've
read it prior to us getting started
formally on the meeting yeah yeah okay
we still need to wait another minute
before we can start properly Thanks
[Music]
okay enough all right good evening
everybody and our visitors this evening
welcome to the Development Committee on
the 9th January 2019 our usual
evacuation announcement before we get
started
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building fire near the nearest available
exit to the chamber our assembly point
is in the public carpark at the side of
the Civic suite please don't delay your
evacuation by collecting belongings you
mustn't return into the building until
given permission to do so by council
staff please also note that the meeting
is audio recorded and if you have a
mobile please turn it to silent or off
thank you item one is apologies for
absence
they've been received from councillor
mrs. Shaw councillor Griffin and council
of Williams item two is our substitute
members such as councillor Lukas kale
and councillor F D item three are
non-members attending we have counselor
mr. high councilor Stanley and
councillor Ward item four is the minutes
of the meeting held on the 13th of
December 2019 a happy for me to sign
those as a correct and accurate record
of that meeting thank you
item 5 then is declarations of interest
counselor mrs. Horry
[Music]
Thank You counsel mr. Hoyt yes I like to
walk sorry Arthur pecuniary interest on
the basis of our property backs on to
the development site okay Thank You
counsel
can I assume that you've seen the
addendum and read that right okay we
must wait for you to read that I'm
afraid our members sound just postponed
for a couple more minutes
okay members were ready to to continue
for our visitors the way the item we've
just got the single item tonight the way
it'll work is our officers will give
their presentation and recommendation we
then have two speakers that of having an
advanced arranged their position that
they'll speak for a maximum of five
minutes each
then our non members of the committee
have the opportunity to make any points
that they wish then it's down to the
committee to have their discussion an
alternate ultimately come to a decision
on this item unfortunately there isn't
any further opportunity for our visiting
visitors tonight to take part in the
meeting afraid it is just an observation
that you've got to do tonight there will
be things that you hear that you think
are good things that you hear that that
you'll think of that are bad but please
do your best to restrain your emotions
so that a full and proper deliberation
can take place about members thank you
so mr. Strang land between Windermere
Avenue Malians Lane lower road on bridge
Thank You chairman this application is
to the site to the west of hull bridge
as you see here at this is the
allocations document but to orientate
yourself the settlement of whole bridge
to the East lower road to the south
watery line here and Windermere Avenue
at the top of the site if the site as
you can see from that extract from your
allocations document was released from
the Greenbelt
and then for as a extension to the
settlement so housing is the most
appropriate use and members will be
aware that on the 18th of January 2017
outline planning permission was granted
for five hundred houses the allocation
is actually slightly larger than the
site that you see this and parcels of
land at the top and up here that aren't
included in the application before you
but the development has planning
permission granted by the outline
permission what we're now looking at
tonight is the reserved matters if we
could jump into the second plan please
the outline planning permission in
establishing the principles of the
development you'll see had a network of
roads and parcels of land it established
two access points one Malians line and
the main one around about a flower road
down in the southern part of the site
and you'll see in a moment that the
detailed layout largely reflects those
parcels and principles that are
established it is also established as
you see there the commitment to various
densities that form the characters we'll
talk about as well overall as well the
development would hope to be outward
facing you'll see these elevations these
brown areas to the edges of the parcels
meant to be a sort of an attractive
frontage as opposed to if you like the
rear of houses as you approach hull
bridge at the current time if we could
jump to three please the outline
application also if we can make that a
bit smaller that's great thank you
you'll see that the outline planning the
outline application established this
parameters plan that accepted that the
higher density would be in the middle
part of the site a maximum of three
stories the red areas up to three
stories with two story at the top as a
way of shaping the form that would come
to you later in reserved matters
consequently with that outline
application granted reserved matters
were submitted in February last year
those details were initially recommended
to you on the 19th of July for refusal
by officers because two main reasons the
house types that were submitted officers
felt they didn't comply or a large
number of them didn't comply with the
national space standards on floor space
and cupboard storage but also the County
Council's urban designer was fairly
critical of the sort of architectural
detailing the makeup of the buildings it
was over reliant on the landscaping and
he felt that it wasn't good enough to
recommend members to approve the
application was requested just before
you considered it by the applicants to
be given the opportunity to
reconsider the position and to provide
revised plans and subsequently on the
19th members deferred the application
the applicants have now gone away if we
can look at plan four please and revise
the application and they have
substituted each house type the designs
that were initially proposed have all
been scrapped if you like and new house
designs which we'll take you through in
a moment have been substituted the
layout as you can see because of the
outline framework established is the
same again the road coming up through to
the middle part of the site Malians Lane
here the roundabout at the bottom of the
sites and the parcels of land and you'll
see from the layout the outward facing
as well as the landscaping and the
subsystems all around the development
the house types they all now comply with
the national space standards they're all
either at the gross or SMO STUV them are
exceeding the gross the only slight
failing and it is a minor failing is
that some of those house types and by no
means all have a slight shortage of
cupboard space of less than one square
metre an officer's consider that not to
be sufficient to warrant a refusal in
actual fact the applicants measurements
through computer packages and techniques
they argue that they comply but officers
measurements with our own computer
package and techniques we have to report
to you that the tools we have put them
under in some of them under in that in
that way but it's such a minor failing
in some cases at point 1/4 of a square
meter it's not of such substance - - I
think concern you hints we feel that
view has been overcome now on the urban
design issues as I said the there was a
concern for the 3 storey massing that
was expressed largely by third parties
as opposed to the urban designer if we
can look at plan five please this is the
massing plan that previously you saw and
the red and the purple are the higher
storeys the yellow is your two-story
developments this is the plan that's not
before you tonight but I'm going to show
you the one that is for comparison the
yellow are the two-story buildings you
see this higher land here where the
anyway the farm buildings are or were
the purple is the three-story buildings
the only genuine three-story buildings
are the flatted units and the red is the
two and a half story one's the ones with
the rooms in the roof sometimes with
with dormice that you see the applicant
has done what they can to improve this
they've taken the three storey building
up there which has also been redesigned
and located it on the lower land down
here they've moved this building here
down to this part and they've made some
substitutes on some of the Reds there
they've become two-story yellows so
they've done what they can to help
address the concerns people had about
the proximity of taller buildings on the
higher parts of the site if we can see
the current version of this plan six
plays there we see the the current
layout you'll still see that there's as
per their outline plans the predominance
of the highest story where you see the
red which was established at outline but
here is the new three-story building
here we see the one move down and you'll
see the three-story buildings which
becomes relevant largely punctuated the
architecture is you would progress
through the site there corner turning
buildings there landmarks it's important
to the urban designer that that scale
reflects a sense of place in the overall
scheme where's that the criticism before
was perhaps that it was more ad hoc and
had no consistency and it needed to be
improved before they could support it to
you if we look at the first harbor
please plan seven I'm taking you through
the character areas from the parkland
quarter at the site into the village
core and then the Northern Quarter of
the top this is one of the house types
that's chosen for the parkland quarter
that is on entry to the site from the
roundabout on lower road that southern
part of the site has a density around
about 35 dwellings per hectare the
layout has a strong relationship to the
green spaces and parts that you saw that
on the Crescent as you run into the to
the site if we see planet please this
gives you an artist's impression as it
were that's okay this gives you sort of
a artist impression as you would sweep
into the site
with the pavement the Parkland of asset
and you've seen from the site plan we
returned to perhaps later how the street
curves on entry to the sites it sweeps
up to the high ground and taking
advantage of that if we could jump to
nine please this is one of the
affordable house types I will be showing
you market housing and the affordable
housing types so that you can see that
the architectural detailing is the same
it isn't going to be you know you easily
spotted which of those types that's the
purpose of the designs is to make sure
that it doesn't matter what tenure it is
from an architectural point of view you
wouldn't be able to distinguish which
buildings are which there is a slight
scale issue because the affordable
housing element obviously requires a
predominance of smaller house types but
hopefully members can see that the
architectural detailing around the
windows and the features is the same as
that for the the market housing if we
could jump to ten please this is another
artist's impression of that house type
in use here you'll see from the street
scene in a moment the car parking to the
front but note the hedgerows when they
mature and the mature planting that goes
in as best he can to soft and the impact
of the parking courts which was one of
the concerns that the urban designer had
in the scheme in the summer if we could
jump to eleven please this is a street
scene comparison now the above street is
the street that was before you in June
and this is the same part of the street
here on to the Crescent has now proposed
for you to consider tonight so so this
is an improvement on on this if you
follow now there's the introduction of
more hip routes that you'll see in part
hip roofs and you'll see that there's an
introduction of chimney stacks you'll
see the materials changing the use of
renders and sort should have been type
in this character area they've gone for
a pitch drove dormers that was a
criticism before but it's not endemic
throughout the scheme that they're all
pitched roof for reasons of architecture
but you'll see that because this follows
the arts-and-crafts Georgian Edwardian
styling and they've taken that
criticism of a flat dormice and they'd
put that in as part of the architectural
makeup that's before you tonight if we
can jump to 12 please this is another
street comparison in the same area this
is the area with the affordable house
types and I mentioned earlier the image
with the planting and the trees there's
a concern that we rather blend the
applicants have taken the image from
these house types to these ones which
are now proposed and though it's on a
small scale you should be able to pick
up changes to the doorways and the porch
details here and you'll also see the
vents at the top of the ridge lines and
some of the house type changes to again
reflect that architectural Arts and
Crafts movement
the windows are Edwardian in style and
the window heads have gone from flat
gauged arch to to brick arches if we
could look at 13 please this I think is
the last in the area this is over this
side and again the elevations at the top
are what was previously before you've
deemed unacceptable the elevations on
the second plan are now what they've
become the buildings are broadly in the
same position you'll notice changes to
the garage in positions more space more
use of hip roofs the door surrounds and
timber porches are of character is also
rafter feet some of you may be familiar
where some of the old rafters in the
loft used to sort of poke out above the
the brickwork because they come down
it's probably other than those with a
keen eye can see that detailing there
but that's subtle changes and
improvements to all the designs the new
designs to distinguish between what we
had before and what we've now got for
members to consider tonight that was the
parkland quarter if we could jump to
village core please plan 14 this
character is in the middle part of the
site the density now goes up to between
35 and 45 dwellings per acre it has a
more urban grain to it you'll see that
the window changes are more contemporary
of sort of a
sort of fashion not particularly I aging
in character but of it of its time there
are three story flatted buildings which
will we'll see in the images shortly
this house type is a typical market
house if we could look at plan 15 please
members were noted also that one was a
two and a half story form whose rooms in
the roof this is one of the affordable
house types in this character area
you'll see a game because of its size
because of the demand for two-bedroom
places but hopefully you'll have picked
up the door proportions that the columns
and details are more sort of urban
filled between these designs now as we
go into the more central core part of
the development but the same materials
and proportions that the character
displays if we could see 17 please I'm
sorry yeah could jump back to 16 sorry
my mistake that's important this one
this is an artist view as you see from
the street what you can see look is the
sort of relationship of the buildings to
the street the small hedgerows and
protective knee rails that landscaping
the human scale the surface treatments
what you'll also see is the flatted
buildings with more articulation and
choice of materials in the end but also
how they they used to turn the corners
as I said earlier on rather than being
just placed in good spaces they've now
been put in logical positions in the
layout so that it reads well
architectural is you would work through
through the scheme sorry if we could
jump to 17 this again is a Street
comparison this shows you the flatted
buildings are either end the scheme
above here again was what you had before
this is now the scheme as improved
you'll see the change in the materials
on the elements the articulation in the
buildings and you'll see some subtle
change if you're lucky you can see the
changes to the windows and door frames
the door surrounds are simplified to
reflect a more urban or suburban feel to
what the other two character areas would
demonstrate if we could jump to 18
please
this Street comparison is still in the
village core area the central part of
the site running through here again what
you had before you before and then what
you have before you tonight again
garages have been improved still the
flat dormer features but you'll see that
proportions and the detailing to the
buildings are different and that the
there's also a use of render and
surface materials on the on the walling
in relation to the roofing lastly if we
look at the northern Court so we only
have the house types for these but your
if I take you through some of the market
houses you'll see again that the
importance of the doors the windows the
proportions if we could jump to the next
one please
okay see variation on the same theme and
again to the next one
at house type there with a sort of an
under Croft parking besides slightly
smaller in scale but your see in
character features in common between
these like like members of a family as
it were if we could jump to the Haven
Gore 21 here we see in this part you're
looking at classical architecture
installed by Georgian influence is
probably a good example of the
collection of the houses we have see the
rendering the cornice details around the
buildings to give them that that
classical feel as well as the entrance
porch details and lastly if we could go
to the n52 please 22 this again is
affordable housing dwelling in that in
that low in that character group again
you'll see details in common to the
larger house types the private ones but
this is only smaller largely because of
the demand for affordable housing is
smaller households one and two-person
families that's the character areas
three characters you say the parkland
quarter down by the entrance into the
site moving up to the higher ground in
the middle of site which is the village
core the more urban suburban feel and
then the lower density northern water of
around 25 to 35 dwellings at the top in
the vicinity of Windermere Avenue now if
we could just look at the affordable
housing plan please 23 one of the
criticisms before was whether the
affordable housing will be better
Pepperpot it scattered through the
layouts members will appreciate from a
lot of applications that we've
considered sense that the housing
associations will not take over
scattered individual dwellings it
doesn't work for them operationally so
what they will accept is what we call
small clusters so here we have a group
here down here of the part equity
schemes the power equities are in a
purple some of which are at the top
there the blue are the social housing
for rent units and you'll see that the
whilst it's a single building where the
flats are obviously there's eight flats
in those building six or eight flats so
there's a multiple use that the provider
can work with and they're used to
bookend as I say the corner
of these streets and the blocks that are
there but officers definitely feel that
the proportion and layout of the
affordable housing prevents any sort of
ghetto ISM whatever where the pepper
potting was designed to achieve to make
sure there wasn't a them and asked
situation in any light so that's been
successful the conclusion is that the
applicants have now overcome the
previous concerns and objections is
raised you'll see in the report that
there was a number of concerns that
members picked up in the 19th of July
which I haven't gone through but they're
set out in the report which you will
have read on the addendum there are a
number of representations from Holdridge
parish council the Holdridge residents
association British Horse Society Roth
Flood Action Group and 23 further
neighbor letters that you'll see have
been summarized and set out for you on
the addendum the recommendation is
approval subject to the conditions that
you'll see at the front of the ripple
thank you gentlemen our first speaker is
mr. hatten
let me know when you've got a minute to
go you just put the mic on
our good evening members and thank you
for the opportunity to speak this
evening my name is ray Houghton and on
the head of planning at Barrett's David
Wilson Holmes Eastern Counties based in
transferred as you know this is an
allocated site in your local plan and
benefits from outline consent as wazirs
matters application the proposal seeks
solely to propose details relating to
layout scale design and external
appearance all other matters including
highways drainage and flood appraisal
have already been approved the reserved
matters application was deferred as you
know in July for two principal reasons
first of which was the requirements
complied with the naturally described
space standards and secondly the
improvements required to the design an
overall layout and distinctiveness of
the character areas I'm pleased to
confirm that obviously each of the house
types complies with this base tanners
satisfying the first reason for the
deferment in relation to the second
point extensive additional consultation
has taken place particularly with Essex
County Council's principal urban design
officer as a result the County Council
considers that the scheme has and I
quote a substantial amount of work has
been put into the redesign resulting in
three distinct character areas and the
considered approach to many other
aspects of the scheme Essex adds that
the revised proposal is of a much higher
quality and says the design and so
represents a significant improvement the
members were looking for therefore we
consider the second the second reason
for deferment has also been addressed
with regards the British horse society
the removal of condition 38 relating to
the boiler path as approved by this very
same Committee on the 24th of May last
year the approved master plan does not
include a vital part I referred members
to paragraph three point one two of your
office's report which states that we are
not proposing to remove a vital path as
none exists nor as one previously
proposed
as its cants counsel highway strongly
objected to the bottle path on safety
grounds due to the obvious conflicts of
encouraging horses on to a housing site
we are proposing a circulatory footpath
to augment the existing public
right-of-way so significant improving
pedestrian and cycle connectivity the
district's has a persistent and
significant under supply of housing by
our David Wilson owned the site and we
are keen to commence delivery of it as
soon as possible so he can contribute to
the housing supply and assists in
eliminating the housing shortfall also
this would reduce the risk of the
council being perhaps susceptible to
haast our applications been submitted by
third parties on unallocated sites the
benefits proposed include all
appropriate mix of housing types to
address pressing local and national need
a wide choice of drawings to provide the
right homes in the right location policy
compliant affordable housing and the
council has a nomination device on the
affordable homes meaning that the
authority will have the opportunity to
allocate homes to those with local
connection local opportunities for
employment during the construction phase
a 2.2 million pounds of education
contributions and increase in the
viability of local shops services and
facilities to help assist in the
vitality of Holdridge also we're looking
at the the the needs of groups of the
specific housing requirements this has
been addressed for the provision of 17
wheelchair accessible dwellings
including five bungalows this exceeds
the requirements of condition 33 of the
outlined consent as stated in your
office's report there are no outstanding
material planning reasons why the
deferred proposal cannot now be approved
as recommended thank you we have
contractors standing by and people to
commence as soon as possible the
approved roundabouts on lower road will
be operational before the first rolling
is occupied and the roundabouts on war
with Lane would be delivered by the 50th
occupation
I hope this demonstrates our commitment
to the area and to the primary objective
of delivering a range of much-needed
high-quality homes of the type that you
see before you this evening we've
consulted widely throughout the the life
of the the application and particularly
since the the July deferment
we've met swore counselors and have a
positive ongoing dialogue with the
parish council who raised no objection
and actually are supportive of the
scheme with the reasons for deferral not
now fully addressed and no objections
from strategy council teas I
respectfully ask members to approve the
application this evening thank you thank
you next speaker is Topsham
[Music]
again up five minutes I'll let you know
when you've got a minute left you just
flick the microphone on the boys
[Music]
thank you good evening chairman
councillors ladies and gentlemen thank
you for the opportunity to direct to
address this committee tonight I'm sue
Dobson representing both the British
Hall society and the Essex bridleway
Association and our speaking objection
to the scheme under consideration
tonight insofar as it relates to the
provision of your questions rather than
the details of the housing proposals
themselves the officer report in
paragraph 3.12 refers to the removal of
the condition to provide a bridleway
within the development despite this
being required with a local development
plan and as agreed within the outline
permission granted against application
1481 300 UT we responded to the
consultation for this application asking
for amendments to be made to the scheme
under consideration bearing in mind the
removal of the bride away condition
those all users including equestrians
could safely access the exit points
specifically within Malians lane
harrison gardens and Windermere Avenue
which would have been an acceptable
compromise in this in this case the
officer report ignores this request and
initially did not even acknowledge it
but as a result of the addendum you
published recently it does at least
acknowledge our representations the
removal of the bridleway in our opinion
was a great loss riders at present have
no use no choice but to use the busy
watery lane lower road to access the
bridleway south of the site and the by
way of Paul's Lane to the Northeast
although the creation of new public
highways by virtue of this proposed
estate will serve to give riders a safe
for you truth albeit on the estate roads
since members will be aware of a
significant horse population in the
vicinity the new estate will most
certainly be extremely well used as a
cut-through for riders so surely it is
safer for such bold reducers to be able
to access access off-road routes the
British Hall Society took legal advice
and resolution made by this committee on
the 24th of May 2018 to approve the
removal of the bridal a condition and
this resulted in the letter of challenge
to Rochford district council Essex
County Council and the developer in
early December setting out the grounds
for potential judicial review
proceedings to which the council has not
had the courtesy to reply although I
note that this has in fact been uploaded
onto the portal against the planning
application 1800 1:00 to 4:00 ful the
letter sets out issues with regard to
the councillors resolution being legally
flawed especially in view of the
original officer reports being wholly in
favor of the retention of the bridleway
condition but changed at the 11th hour
too late for any member of the public to
register to speak in objection to that
change of heart I would presume that
members here tonight have been apprised
of the letters contents as it has the
direct relevance to the determination of
this application tonight members will
note that no decision notice has yet
been issued relating to the council
resolution taken on that date the letter
our subcommittee be reconvened to
properly hear the application again
there being no decision notice yet
issued so that the correct procedures
can be followed and the committee can
properly consider the safety and
connectivity points raised in the
application we therefore ask that a the
development committee is reconvened to
reconsider this application and B the
decision to approve or otherwise this
application tonight is either deferred
until the outcome of the reconvene
meeting is decided or to approve or
otherwise this reserve matters
application with the proviso that the
bridleway link will be provided as
originally required under the local
development plan and set out in the
approval of the outline application
thank you for listening to me
counselor mr. Hawaii Thank You chairman
I'm firstly just on a matter of process
I understand I have to and for benefit
of members of public president because I
have another pecuniary interest I have
to leave the room once I've spoken it's
that once I've spoken or once the debate
starts amongst members of the committee
once the debate starts okay so I come
wait here
yeah don't count on me I've spoken now
thank you thank you I will be fairly
brief the the improvements to the plans
are unquestionably there I wouldn't
dispute that but I would also say that
it would be hard not to improve on the
plans which were first submitted and
it's disappointing that these plans
weren't didn't come forward first I
think I'm still not happy I'm not happy
about to me but I'm not happy that two
of the flat EDA buildings the
three-story fled two buildings are still
on still cited on the higher ground yes
to have been removed to lower ground the
two are still just under the pair of the
hill and us I still think would be quite
prominent in the in the design of
anybody approaching whole bridge from
the whole bridge road direction I'm
disappointed they could not have also
been moved further down the hillside
given the fact that we've been told that
the outline permission gave the right
for the three-story buildings to be
there are just like confirmation as well
from the the offices that because one of
my ritual cursors was around the
immediacy space I was verbally told that
the amenity space is now in place for
all the flatted buildings because
they've now got the inclusion of
balconies on some of the more thing
which weren't there in the first place
can I please have confirmation whether
or not the amenity space does now comply
with their policy for all the flatted
buildings or if it doesn't which flatty
building it doesn't do so on johner do
it as I go what do you want me to you
carry on carry on and then you do at the
end and they're not good I'll go also
I've had a verbal assurance from mr.
Howe to drill one of the meetings that
the
that the garage is all met our policy
sighs Kenny can that also be confirmed
because I haven't been able to check
that myself not like in make setting
public if it does or doesn't as well
thank you
also there's let's mention rent density
and I think the whole bridge residence
Association of have mentioned about
density and I think there's a an error
in one of the where it's been
transferred on to a report that they've
mentioned in the report it says they
took about 15 buildings two hectare it's
I think it's around 30 to 35 buildings I
think it's just a typo in one of the
reports and I just will name emphasized
as well there that the careers on a
raise I can't raise HEVC on which is be
passed outlined however I wouldn't bring
up about the red backs I know the
roundabout has been the roundabouts on
lower on lar Road which is the
roundabout at the bottom of the plan in
mr. Harrison's report verbal report just
now you mentioned the roundabout and
that's why we were raised and it's also
mentioned in a report which I think was
also sent to all counselors and I just
want this clarified and cleared up in
the approval outline approval on the
22nd of March 16 or the the planning
application putting in on what was
approved from that application at what
the the report issued on the 18th of
January it states that the roundabout
will be built prior to the commencement
of the work not prior to the occupation
I understand it would appear on the 23rd
of January it measure getting to the
legal agreement there is a wording it
doesn't say roundabout it says highway
improvements will commence prior to the
first occupation everywhere I've read it
says prior to commencement the
roundabout will be built not prior to
occupation when the revision to the
round of air came in and was passed by
the committee on the 24th of May 2018
and that's the revision of the
roundabout when they bTW Holmes also
added the
lay-by which nothing was a suggestion of
castle mrs. Hawaii which was very
gratefully received that was then it
passed again as a roundabout and again
said the same thing
prior to Gawker my words right again now
prior to commencement again so they're
out back and that application when that
was approved says prior to commencement
the roundabout when we built there's
nothing in that nothing that has been
passed by this committee or or previous
meetings of this committee as if I said
prior to occupation it has always been
prior to commencement so it's like that
reiterated and addressed finally not
finally sort of Mitchum bungalows
because there's great fuss about the
number of bungalows on this site five
and I understand that five is five more
than any other development I've seen
come through off this scale however the
five are clearly inadequate the five as
well I'd like to say off for affordable
rent or purchase they're not for private
sale
which I don't understand and I really
feel let down that the site could not
find more land for bungalows or or the
way to get more bungalows in for private
sale which are desperately wanted I know
is an elderly population in the district
16 halbridge as many people who'd like
to move to downscale or upscale to from
a house we stairs to a bungalow with no
stairs and it's just not being made
available to them in any of these new
developments and then finally I move on
to the about landscaping which is part
of of this I'm fairly happy they're now
escaping however with regard to the
brighter well now it's come up before
has come up again it's been being
altered and it's been removed
is it possible and I'd like this
considered that the bride away could be
added by African
addition to the landscaping or or with
with a view of consultation with walk
members for the addition of a bride away
or or access for horses to the
I this is something which was I think
he's need I think it's a mistake by
Essex highways again saying that it
wasn't needed not thinking the first
report they didn't say they objected
they I think they said they didn't see
than the need for it I think Tier II
there is a need and the need has been
demonstrated and I just like to know
whether or not that could be a Depot
ever condition via the landscaping part
of the report thank you
listen to the count sir Stanley next and
then we'll take some officer response
before you live
councillor Stanley Thank You chairman
I'd like to address I mean the the whole
plan looks looks viable and apart from a
few requests by Councillor high on
bungalows and other parts what concerns
me most is that it doesn't seem to be
much liaison with the council and the
community that where this is going the
they have been I know there's been a few
if you like the meetings but not enough
meetings for for those people in that
community hull bridges I really sort of
his own village and this is really a
major major thing for that village to
work from and I do feel that the camp
the council should have or perhaps done
a little bit more in their way of
consultation in their way of talking to
the village rather than hoping that
they're going to come forward and speak
to them because he is the council that
he's going to say yay or nay to this
development several things there's
there's lots of things that that perhaps
the our DC are not aware of of what the
NP PF and lots of community involvement
the regulation 25 and many other things
that have come to light and it doesn't
seem to be a
addressed by the by our DC and I asked
the officers that should we or should
they have done a little bit more beyond
their remit to to contact those people
at whole bridge the whole bridge
residents Association and all those that
are involved I think you know more the
more you put into it the more effort the
officers will put into it the better it
becomes for those residents at hole
bridge
thank you yeah would you like to make
some comments before we go on to the
committee to say discussion Thank You
chairman taking the last point first the
the applications when they get revised
of any substance or subject to public
consultation exercise that's normally
site notices and direct neighbor
notification as well as notification
with agencies such as the residents
association now they the residents
Association of submit is something like
seven letters I believe over the last
few months so they're familiar with the
applications and they've submitted quite
detailed responses about a lot of stuff
to do with building regs and other
things but they have definitely
participated as the sort of the written
correspondence that everybody everybody
does there's also been as the applicant
said dialogue with officers County the
specialist advisors and they met with
with more members so district officers
are comfortable the consultations which
others are laid out by statute you write
to these people and ask them for review
back they've they've been undertaken
with regard to the point raised about
the bridle way there is landscaped areas
that you can see on on the plan but the
problem is you can't just set down a
highway path there's certain distances
that the bridle ways I think have to be
from other junctions and then you can't
just so put a fence in as our ride on
that you would have to liaise closely
with the Highway Authority
to meet their standards to be safe and
adopt it now the issue that was raised
by the county before was that you'd be
introducing riders into sort of a
suburban mix and the two things don't
meet if there was a sort of Bridal way
that sort of started on the site just as
you get in suddenly went off across the
adjoining land not within the applicants
control and took the horses away from
the urban development they would have
supported them
it wouldn't have linked up with it
anywhere but because the the the site is
essentially an urban location it's not
like our Jubilee Country Park where
there's a there's a circulatory route
around what is effectively an open space
the the bungalows question I think we've
been successful getting five art I don't
deny that a healthier twirling mix would
be would be more but the problem we have
is that the developers have not got a
market or whatever where they would they
would they would put that so it is a
success I don't deny it Michonne if it
hadn't been more bun goes but we tried
our best and in this case we've
succeeded I've had the opportunity to
check the roundabout commencement and I
do see in the condition drafted I
haven't had a chance to check the legal
agreement but it does refer to prior to
commencement as members have said there
is a slight problem there because if
you're going to commence construction of
the roundabout you can't have necessary
everything coming off that road not all
the equipment Laurie did every things
like this we'll be able to go on to sort
of a meadow surface so a lot of the
construction would have to come in and
wake its way down here and make camp as
it were whilst they then build the
roundabout but I think members can take
comfort that what the applicants have
always said it works for them as well as
everybody else they construct that
roundabout as soon as possible so that
all the construction activity and the
pace of development runs through the
site so there will be some need to come
in elsewhere for the initial stages but
as the development progresses I think if
you're anxious the roundabouts won't be
built I think that you would see that
roundabouts built in those earlier
stages I can't find the error in the
report without a paragraph references to
15 per hit
but in my presentation I did outline the
different densities for the various
character areas I think the lowest
density is 25 at the top and 25 to 30
down here rising to 35 to 45 I believe
in the middle roughly those those
proportions it's not as low anywhere as
15 per hectare okay the the Garrett the
garages they are under sized to your
preferred standard but they exceed your
national minimum sizes so we would
struggle to defend I think a reason to
refuse with saying the garages aren't
big enough I accept that that's a county
wide for most of the county authorities
standard but reason why they're normally
7 meters is so that you can provide
cycle storage and stuff in the back of
the garage which is concealed well
there's the option of providing that in
in the gardens anyway I'm not confident
if members were to hold out for slightly
deeper garages by say a meter that that
would be supported on appeal we did
fight an appeal with KFC on the estate
that's on Cherry Orchard whyyy over the
over the depth of the car parking spaces
and we lost that so some time ago I
concede but nevertheless I don't think
you'd have support on that the county
highway - do not object to the highway
provisions on this this scheme I don't
know if Katie you can zoom in on this
area here and there's a chance the
flatted schemes comply with your amenity
space but the the issue was here with
these ones that are close to the open
space if we can aspect as good now yes
not the amenity space before was a bit
detached from from these buildings and
what the applicants have done I think
they've moved them slightly but they've
created garden amenity spaces in there
which are under size there not 25 per
unit I think that works out about 20 or
so some of the units have got balconies
and we say about Kinnear five square
meters counts these balconies are sort
of four square meters so they're
slightly undersized on that but your
standard does say we're a development B
housing or flats these are joining an
area of public open space and these are
right next to it
that standard can come down and that's
why we're recommending to you that the
scheme can be approved these guys get
the benefit the outlook of this open
space they get direct access to it as
well as anybody else members of the
public they have their own private
amenity space in this case these group
they are slightly under sides and I
think that's it German yeah okay right
are you going to cancel mrs. Howe you
declared a pecuniary interest so we as a
member of the committee sitting as a
member of committee having declared a
pecuniary interest I know
thank you
our members council Steptoe Thank You
German I've got a number of questions
but first of all could I have some
clarification on lately couple of legal
points first and depending on the
answers to where I go we've got
questions with regards to the comments
made by the lady from the horse society
with regards to a judicial potential
judicial review review if that was to be
the case would that stop the whole
development or just with regards to the
potential of the bridle way and secondly
in the addendum item 4 on page 4 and
it's runs into page 5 it comments there
that Russia District Council in breach
of their terms of conditions in ignoring
the legislation approved by the
government of common law and case law
from the high courts can we can you
clarify what that actually means please
first of all on the
so that's something in terms of group
saying they bring reaches something I
mean okay are we counsel cept oh the two
items that you've you've mentioned on
this moment felt to be directly able to
influence the decision we make tonight
but that's chair if I may and in
relation to the potential judicial
review and until we were were to receive
I think a letter before action in
relation to that it's difficult to know
what the applicant would be seeking in
terms of a judicial review it's there
are different remedies available so I
can't really comment to this committee
what the recourse would be until such
application were to be made shouldn't
implement the decision tonight that's a
separate decision it's a separate
process it doesn't relate to the
reserved matters that have been dealt
with it this committee tonight
similarly in relation to the point are
on page 4 page five
unfortunately chat I'm not able to
answer that simply because I can't place
it in in context of knowing which terms
and conditions or which legislation it's
been referenced I'm not sure whether
mister strikes can assist so let me know
whether and any search information was
provided in detail chairman I can't help
you either with the actual naming of the
legislation or parts but what I can say
is the Essex County Council were
consulting on these details this as well
as that there's discharges of conditions
to the outlying consent but on these
details before you Casey's County
Council such team were consulted and
they've raised no objection
to the the schemes and details that you
see before you the size of the sons that
what-have-you so they are content that
it did it works and flows but I'm sorry
I can't help you with what legislation
or sections of that legislation may be
an outstanding issue Thank You chairman
if I can come back my questions please
thank you first of all could if you can
shrink down the drawing you have on the
screen could you point out where the
footpath the proposed footpath will
actually run for me please chairman
you'll see the footpath running through
the site and the edge of the corrosion
and up round so here on the site and
also through two mailings Lane there
this footpath link around the other part
of the site as well around here and
that's a footpath and cycle track yes
okay
I'd still feel that because of the
potential horse use from the site we've
heard from the lady from the hearth
society that it is very likely we're
going to get horses using the estate
roads to make a cut through to existing
systems that it would be better to
regulate that rather than just to leave
it at hoc so I still feel that the
developer should reconsider that a
footpath status and relook at that with
regards to the three storey buildings
that were in the center there the corner
buildings to my mind they look very
industrialized you know because of the
outline the overall look at the design
is it possible to perhaps put a
conditioning that that is softened
slightly so it blends in a little easier
rather and be such quite a hard cold
look on those particular buildings with
regards to the last meeting where the
matter was deferred there was some
discussion with regards to the old farm
buildings that were still on site
there's been no comment on that as to
what is likely to be happening with
those
what's likely to happen to those isn't a
part of the tariff is a particular point
with regards to designed at the
buildings I would like to know whether
any of the proposed of dwellings will be
looked at from the point of view of
greywater systems solar panels those
type of environmental issues thanks Jim
councillor Weston Thank You chairman
I've got a few questions as well if I
may just to go into the horse side it
was only lost by one vote last time we
had a committee here it was determined
it was re it was determined okay I just
wanted to say that and um mr. strength
on the site it's so looking at site can
you tell me or can diagrams tell me
which part of the site is gonna be stage
one of the building I'm only asking
because just I want to just start a
question on the roundabout side is there
a night after they know which part is
gonna be started the first stages of the
the build chairman is my understanding
that this part would be constructed
first and then they've moved into the
middle parts of the site I am less clear
as to whether the contractors for this
would start simultaneously with the
lower part that's not the case I
understand so why I say that is because
David Wilson homes will be developing
the parkland and the northern quarters
and Barrett's arm of the development
dealing with the village core so the
contractors for both would be present on
the site but they're going to be busy it
seems dealing with this first and then
moving into this with Barrett's and then
finishing off at the top with Davey
Wilson homes at the top okay my my my
our question is that is because on the
talking about the roundabout and you're
saying the roundabout will be done once
the maybe the first people move into the
properties so I'm just looking at the
road I'm just concerned about millions
lane bethey you know the
trucks and things going down Malians
Lane in the residence along that road so
as soon as they've done the first stage
of the first houses my questions going
to be will the road be on that estate be
done to match the roundabouts that's
going to be completed or going to be
started at the end so you've got stage
one at the end of that Oh adopted what
do you want to call it you will the
roundabout then go ahead from then to
ma'am I'm not quite sure I understand
the question but the the access to
melons line is existing access to the
farm and public right-of-way they can't
they can't block that out that's right
so when you say will it be done well
you've got the whole Road coming down to
the roundabout because they obviously
from the roundabout off the lower road
you're going to have access into the
estate at the moment you're not going to
do that from that roundabout because a
roundabouts not going to be completed or
started
so my question really is if you're going
to do the first stage at the bottom of
the near the lower road when is the
roundabout going to be when it's around
about going to be started or completed
for that section the roundabout
chairman's like to be started at the
same time they start on this early stage
here I think the aim is to get this in
right so that then they can work and
work fast but they not in order to get
on site to build a roundabout for a time
they're gonna have to bring kit in yeah
some of it you might be able to unload
off the road they're not gonna undertake
a journey with a big excavator or so
they don't have to but to unload it on a
concrete level service so it doesn't
topple cause accident things like this
they need a base to work from and then
they'll bring the machinery down here
the roundabouts will go in and probably
when they're getting the roads and the
drains into a certain stage they start
putting all the footings in and things
here the show homes are here so then
they want the customers and the builders
and everybody ought to start coming in
off that route so I think I can't tell
you an exact date of when it would be
constructed but I think you can have
confidence that this will go in pretty
pretty soon okay I want to know really
and the other question I wanted to ask
is once the development has been
completed will all the roads be adopted
by Essex County Council and they will be
none that won't be unadopted is that
correct no chairman depending on the
numbers of dwellings serves you see
these like private drives and things the
county wouldn't take them over I'll come
my eyes are failing me but maybe some of
these you can see more than five they'd
probably be adoptable but you may be
able to catch me out and find some
little alcoves that have got less than
five and they wouldn't be required to be
adopted but the main the main route all
the way through etc all the feeder roads
if said they'd all be adoptable standard
but there's probably coming off those is
the hierarchy reduces you'll end up
probably at the far ends where there be
some areas serving a limited number of
dwellings that won't be adopted I can't
promise you that every inch of the
highway will be adopted that's a Wilson
thank chairman and on the officer's
report
I've got question of fact on these
paragraph 3.1 to the in the paragraph it
says the letter dated the 16th of May
from Essex County Council highways about
the creation of the bridle-path
but I went back and checked my emails
and the email that was sent with the
Essex highways report on it didn't go
out until the day before at five past
four in the afternoon so I'd like to
check that there is actually was part of
the addendum for that that's that's
given a week's delay if I can then move
on to the next point which is again to
do with the three-story buildings
because reserve matters is about scale
and and mass and that sort of things and
we still got two units two three-story
units that's still at the highest point
in whole bridge and as I've said before
that is the the lowest point of lower
road is that sea level not meters and
that then rises over six hundred meters
up to 20 meters and now I appreciate
that by moving some of the three storey
units there
that's very good but unfortunately
paradoxically by leaving two units on
the skyline it actually draws your
attention to it and traditionally in
development you'd have something like a
church on the eighth on the highest
point of a bill of a piece of land or in
the case of Rayleigh if you've got the
the yeah and and so that draws your eye
to whole bridge we'll have two
three-story building as its apex and
don't believe that that is in in scale
and with regard to the addendum and
there's a couple of points I'd like to
raise the HRA raised about balconies and
I'd like an assurance that none of the
balconies actually overlook existing
properties or if they do that they've
got sufficient space between the
balconies of the of the flats and the
existing buildings and in particular
there's plot to 4 to 42 to 48 and on the
diagram it seems to me that there
overlooks plot 2 3 9 so I'm not sure
whether it whether that's the case then
moving on to the next point which is to
do with the I'm not sure to reserve
matters but it is in the officers
reporting has come up and it's to do
with the understanding that parts of the
estate have being sold off to other
boroughs I'm not sure that's it's not
specifically not not relevant
ok so I'll stop on that one yeah ok and
then finally the is to confirm that the
lighting within the new estate will
conform to Essex highways standards
specifically as LED lighting
okay bring some things together Thank
You chairman Pam where you have
adoptable streets then the lighting
would obviously conform to Essex County
standards but where there may be private
courtyards and areas at the end as I
said in answer to the previous question
then they wouldn't have to build those
two County standards obviously the
designers may build designs that comply
anyway and those may be chosen but you
could only expect to see lighting
compliant to Essex standards on what is
predominantly adopted highway network
the I'm not sure that the geography
where the plots two four eight and two
three nine are but I can show on this
plan the three-story flatted schemes
you'll see it now nowhere near part from
up here and nowhere near anybody
existing and this distance you'd need
for overlooking to be 35 metres between
the windows to the flats and the nearest
dwellings and that is why in excess to
35 metres so I think members can be sure
that the overlooking to existing
residence wouldn't occur from the three
storeys I'd only try and answer the
points it's a matter of taste and
judgment but when you mention was map
that churches and castles and things
there was we put on defensive or
prominent positions for a purpose are
you for defense for castles subjugation
in the case of the church now these
buildings here they as you saw on the
images performer a townscape function
the criticism that the designer had
before was that they were a bit all over
the place is like an afterthought I
would put some of these here I mean he
couldn't read the architecture through
the character areas the architect has
responded to that he's actually changed
the design the appearance of the
building to reflect the that the comment
was made air about their industrial
appearance that say he's done a lot of
work to to make them domestic with the
change in articulation and materials but
these buildings perform a function in
town scape terms so they've done what
they can to to make it better
given the criticism that was levied but
that
that needs to be on that higher ground
in in a different way to the same point
you said about the churches in the
castle's its focal points and as
landmarks but the outline permission
yeah said that the way you can structure
your layout is you can have your
low-density at the top you can have your
two-and-a-half house you can have your
higher density in the middle of a site
so the applicant quite reasonably you
can say right here's what my outline
permission gives me as parameters and
this light up achieves that sustainable
features within the houses sorry
chairman the great water recycling and
solar panels and stuff there's largely
now taken over by the building regs you
quite often see a telltale sign where as
you look at housing development I think
three solar panels on the roof or
something where they try to get a
certain value and if it's not achieved
by the solar tiles or something like
that then but that's now largely left
out of planning because there was a time
when it wasn't covered with the building
regs and planning took it over but
before it really got going under
planning got back into building rings
again so in order to comply with
building regs they will have to satisfy
criteria under building regs on their on
that amount thank you
I so got the microphone mic you go back
to the social housing slide
so one without you got the elevations we
actually showed what was guess way so
there's a social housing caste types
positive potentially please I can't
remember seeing any garages I thought if
there were so if it helps when the
architects show their house types
because it's an assemblage what they do
is they show the house by itself they
don't necessarily show or would have a
garage here and everything else so it's
like a unit there is garage types I
haven't shown them to you know other
than in the street scenes but you all
have seen that what they did one of the
many things they try to do going back to
the the character that I was trying to
impose they went away from gable ended
doubles to hip ended or hip ended
singles so you saw in the street scene
that there was sort of new spaciousness
around some of those runs there was in I
think there's the second or third image
in if we can go back to the site dome
the area here which is affordable
housing in that n club in that
particular character there isn't I don't
think there's any garages there parking
spaces and that was one of the concerns
of the urban designer had before he felt
that it be highway dominated but he
didn't appreciate the landscaping
treatment that was was coming in to
soften that up and you saw in the visual
image when I said here's the house type
and then you saw the street scene with
the porches and you could see the the
cars parked between dwarf dwarf hedges
so in town scope that's it in town scope
terms we we felt well that that's that's
acceptable but not everybody has to have
necessary a garage but the applicants
spent some time the the landscaping has
been an essential part of the layout not
an afterthought so the urban designer is
comfortable that even though it's
affordable housing in the vehicles are
parked in in a in a four core with the
success of the landscape in and you've
got really good competent Landscape
Architects doing this that it should be
you know largely give it a few years
what you see there okay it brings me on
to my next point
which was is going to be 500 houses
probably in excess of 500 plus cars
with air quality I haven't heard
anything about electric charging points
or because normally you need off street
parking spark plug a car into there's no
mention of that pin at all Chairman I
don't think whole bridges in an air
quality management area but I don't I'm
not aware of any electric charging
points in in the layouts I think the the
applicant would have to make a decision
whether there was a market for that
whether it was desirable by the by the
purchases and maybe retro put them in
but I'm not aware in the streets escapes
that we've been looking at that charging
points are throughout or fundamental
through this game and also with the
money here to alter cycling and it's got
what is route 135 Chairman are that
that's in the outline application there
was a number of infrastructure
commitments that the outline set that
these applicants then been purchased and
are now obligated by and one of those is
a highway route that crosses through
this district I'm not sure if it comes
from chumford or further afield but
there's a stretch of it and that they
are contributing a hundred hundred grand
towards okay say see I said stock to
South End or just one who's actually
coming through gosh good thing yeah I
think part of that really comes sorrow
comes through therefore is it there's a
contributor they're not whole and the
whole thing but the the 500 dwellings
has been argued by county to generate
their I understand what it means I just
want to make sure it actually we got
some benefit as a district from it I
think okay members Oh Nelson council
Wilson you want to come back
they said one final point it carries on
from the point counsel set tone made
which was about the judicial review but
is it possible before the judicial
review if it ever happens to put a
conditioning that allows the question
and access as was suggested in the
addendum I would say we made a decision
about the Questor and access back in May
were more than six months since we made
that decision so I suppose anything's
possible but we have got clear advice
from the Highways Authority about them
not wanting that we have also got or
heard from mr. Strang about a series of
conditions that may mean that anything
we condition could simply not be
deliverable because of its viability and
sustainability so I personally don't
think it would be appropriate for us to
go down that route sir certainly the
developer is is here tonight and has
heard the concerns be made and I mean if
I if I was going down that line I would
say that's an informative along the
lines of noting the level of concern
about horses how it will be handled and
potential future developments be noted
concerned and consider for action I
think that would be potentially as far
as we could reasonably go bearing in
mind we are making a significant and
important and insistence and it needs to
be a properly for sustainable decision
tonight Jake just picking up on your
point there of an informative I think
that's a very good idea but I would pass
that can suggest that the developer
meets and discusses with the British
horse society on ways of overcoming
their concerns and their problems I
think that's something we could simply
ask the developer to do I think you've
just common sense really there are legal
words if I quite agree we can't make a
request for a meeting part of our
decision that's something that we need
to deal with outside can't let it
conflict with the decision we make
tonight that's the Luca scale Thank You
chairman is there any hope sometime in
the future public transport will go on
to this development and if so will the
roads be wide enough to well we part
part of the decision we made a contra
what date it was we do have a bus stop
at the end of the at the end of the side
on the on Bridge Road yeah chairman the
the road hierarchy that the bus would
get in so far and then as the roads
reduce in width is called into the
numbers of dwellings left it wouldn't be
able to get out through through Malians
lane so the existing bus routes are down
here and up Ferry Road there's a bus
stop a comp remember precisely the
relocation of it but it's down here on
on lower road to serve passengers coming
through this way unless they walk
through same aliens Lane and pick up the
bus stop from from ferry Ferry Road
whichever works for them there's another
bus stop just around the corner from
from budgets but the the bus stop
provision to serve this development
highways of have asked for that's down
here somewhere
yes but the because the the sort of the
highway structure through it and and to
try and avoid rep runs although they
can't stop up Malians line that the
roads I don't think are adequate enough
to take a bus through it's not like the
whole road development has got a major
like six meter wide carriageway all the
way through in a loop and a roundabout
at one end and a t-junction the other
this this feeds the development point
most of the traffic in here will go out
in and out through here but in order to
give you a connection to shops and
schools and and other things and then
assimilate into the village then it
needs to be an access here as well as
the various pedestrian access points
that through the sites are to to give
you permeability but I can't see a bus
coming out through through Malians line
the the junction isn't it just wide
enough or big enough okay how's the hog
way Thank You chairman um first you like
to comment on the fact that it's been a
number of points race and looking back
at some of the history of this in
relation to what would seem to be a
disappointingly late notice of some
reports and information provided which
is subsequently had an impact on
decisions made by this committee because
if some of the information had been a
bit more prompting earlier we might have
had the opportunity of listening to one
of the speaker's this evening an earlier
stage and that may have made a
difference to what was determined
previously so I'll just stop you there
for a moment I hear what you're saying
but the meeting is conducted properly
the report is put together properly
legal advice is taken properly it is a
proper decision that we make so although
you may have concerns they are this is a
properly determined decision and each
meeting
each decision has been properly made it
may be it may well be properly it may
well the process may well be proper but
it may not necessarily have been
actually been shall we say open to
everyone to be able to participate in it
which i think is a fail in any way
despite that mmm I would support the
suggestion put forward by councillor
Wilson because it's not real uh 'king
act a decision that was made because
we're not he's suggestion by condition
was not to reintroduce a bride away but
to look at access points which was a
suggestion made in the addendum and I
think that that is an appropriate way to
go forward and so I would support
councillor Wilson's suggestion in
relation to a condition regarding that
and I think it's appropriate to say that
if we unless we help equestrian activity
the and have some kind of control
aniyah's counselor step-touch as
mentioned previously the likelihood is
it's going to all be ad hoc and
uncontrolled thank you thank you there
are any final points that you wish to
make before we go to a decision okay
members we have a recommendation for
approval printed on 6.1 to be
supplemented by an informative with
regard to equestrian access points to
look at the viability of our to consider
the viability of putting equestrian
route route through or brought broaden
it through and so on I think the
strengths do you have enough information
to construct that informative based on
what members have discussed
okay thank you so those members in favor
of the approval as printed please
indicate those against that item is
carried now that that item is carried
were now also make the request that the
developer meets with the question
representative groups to further discuss
and to see whether they can come to some
compromise okay thank you right thank
you very much members meeting closed